In early August 1914, we
know that Germany declares
war on Russia, just as
Russia's mobilizing troops
to get into a war with the
Austro-Hungarian Empire.
Because the Austro-Hungarians
have declared war on Serbia.
And the Russians
apparently, or ostensibly,
or used protection of
Serbia as a pretext
for getting into war
with the Austrians.
The Germans have an
alliance with the Austrians.
So they feel the need
to fight the Russians.
And then, because the
Russians have an alliance
with the French, to
fight the French as well.
The first actual combat
on the Eastern Front
actually happens with
Russia on the offensive.
And you actually have
two Russian armies.
The Russian First Army and
the Russian Second Army
attacking the Germans up
here in Eastern Prussia.
And they were going against one
German army, the German Eighth
Army.
And in theory, it
should have been
a route of the
German Eighth Army.
They had them outnumbered.
You had two Russian
armies coming
from different directions.
But because of really
bad coordination and, one
could even argue, bad leadership
and other tactical problems,
it was actually a
route the other way.
So the war, World War
I, on the Eastern Front,
starts very badly
for the Russians.
You actually have a
huge route of them
at the Battle of Tannenberg.
And Tannenberg's interesting
because it actually
did not even happen
in Tannenberg.
Tannenberg is right around here.
It wasn't far from the
point of the battle.
But there was other cities
that would have been more,
the battle could
have been named for.
But since the Germans
won the battle,
they named it
Tannenberg because there
was an ancient battle in
medieval times in the 1400s
where the Slavic,
some Slavic peoples
were able to route
German Teutonic knights.
We're talking about medieval
battles with knights.
And in order to redeem that,
they labeled this other war
where it was Germans
against Slavic people.
They said, oh, this is our
second battle for Tannenberg.
So it helped bring out
more German patriotism.
But this was a major, major,
major route for the Russians.
The Second Army, in particular,
got completely decimated.
The Second Army, the
Russian Second Army
went into the battle-- I've
seen estimates of 150,000
to 180,000 troops.
Roughly half were killed.
And only about 10,000 escaped
the Battle of Tannenberg.
And it was such a humiliating
defeat for the Russian Second
Army.
But that the general of the
Russian Second Army, General
Samsonov-- and I'm
sure once again,
I'm mispronouncing everything--
General Samsonov actually
shot himself.
He committed suicide.
He was so humiliated and so
embarrassed by that defeat.
So the war did not begin
well for the Russians.
But by the end of
1914, they were
able to get back into gear.
And they stayed
on the offensive.
And they did have
some victories up here
in Galicia which,
at the time, was
part of northeastern Hungary.
And so they were
actually able to capture
a good bit of territory
right over here.
Now, as we enter into
1915, and we've already
covered this on the videos
on the Western Front.
We know that the Western Front
was entering into a stalemate.
The Schlieffen Plan did not
happen as quickly as possible.
But the defenders
had a huge advantage.
So that gave the
Germans an opportunity
to bring some troops back
to the Eastern Front,
to bring troops back
to the Eastern Front.
They also got better
at coordinating
with the Austro-Hungarians.
And so you have 1915, you
have the Central Powers
go back on the offensive.
And they're essentially
able to drive
the Russians out
of Russian Poland
roughly to this border that
I have drawn right over here,
roughly to this border, give
or take, right over here.
When we talk about Russian
Poland, the modern state
of Poland, I'm making
this video now in 2013.
The modern state of
Poland was essentially
split between what
you see on this map
between the Russian Empire
and the German Empire.
The modern state of Poland
is roughly this region right
over here.
And so you see, it's
almost completely
split, almost like a yin and
yang symbol between these two
empires.
But by, but through
1915, the Russians
were pushed out of Russian
Poland roughly to this border.
And essentially, to a large
degree, it was because Russia,
even though they had this
huge army, this huge manpower,
they had bad
communication lines.
And actually had bad
technical supplies.
Russian industry
wasn't able to keep up
with the demand of
the war and wasn't
able to supply the munitions
in proper quantities
and the arms in proper
quantities to their troops.
As you enter into 1916,
the Russians, once again,
were able to get
their footing back.
As you can see, it's starting
to become a little bit of a back
and forth.
So Russian industry,
I guess you could say,
picks back up in 1916.
And it essentially puts the
Russians more on the offensive.
They were driven out
of Russian Poland.
But now by 1916, they're able
to keep the Central Powers
a little bit more
on the defensive.
But the boundaries
of the front roughly
stay in line with this
line right over here.
And by the end of
1916, you actually
have the Romanians joining on
the side of the Triple Entente,
on the sides of the
Russians, in order
to fight the Central
Powers as well.
Now, this might look
like it's starting
to look better for the Russians.
The Russians, their industry
is finally picking up.
They're starting to put the
Central Powers a little bit
more on the defensive.
But the entire time
that we're talking
about this battle, the economic
situation in the Russian Empire
is deteriorating dramatically.
By the time you get into
1917, the Russian economy
is really falling apart.
You have food shortages.
You have riots.
Food shortages.
And in February of 1917, you
have the February Revolution.
You essentially, the overthrow
of the Romanov Dynasty.
It's been in power
for 300 years.
But you have Tsar Nicholas II.
So this is in February.
And then in early March,
you have Tsar Nicholas II
abdicates the throne.
And this is the
gentleman right here.
And we'll do more
detailed videos
about the entire
Russian Revolution
and what happens to his
family and all of the rest.
And you have an interim
government that takes place.
And this is actually
a little, this
is an interesting
fact of history.
This interim government all of
a sudden becomes a democracy.
This is February 1917.
Remember, the United
States has not
entered the war at this point.
But you might also remember
that in April, the United States
uses the idea of fighting
on the side of democracy
as a justification
for entering the war.
Which is very nice,
because by April,
all of the major powers
on the side of the,
I guess you would say,
the Triple Entente,
they were all democracies.
You're talking about, now,
the interim government
for the Russians.
You have the French.
And you have the British Empire.
Obviously, it's a democracy
only for those who are voting.
And actually the United
States was the first country
to recognize the
interim government
after the overthrow
of Tsar Nicholas II.
But we're not just
done with 1917.
1917 is one of those huge years
in the history of the world
and especially in the
history of Russia.
The situation continues
to deteriorate.
And it starts to deteriorate,
as well, for the army.
The morale and the
troops breakdown.
You start having, the Bolsheviks
start to create unrest.
By the end of 1917, now we're
talking about September 1917.
So that's maybe
right around here.
You have the Central Powers.
Germany's able to capture
Riga, which is a major city
right over here on the Baltic.
Which brings the Central
Powers very, very
close to the Russian capital.
It contributes to the ongoing
unrest that's going on.
And so in November 7,
you have coup d'etat
of that ostensibly democratic
interim government,
provisional government.
And you have the
communists take power.
You have the
Bolsheviks take power
under the leadership of
Vladimir Lenin right over here.
So November 7, 1917, very
famous date in history.
You have the Bolsheviks.
So this is Lenin leading
the Bolsheviks into power.
Now, they were in no
interest to continue
fighting this
battle with Germany.
They had their own civil
war to worry about.
They were trying to
consolidate power in Russia.
So in December, they
essentially get into,
start to negotiate an armistice
with the Central Powers.
And they did not have a lot of
leverage in this negotiation
because they
weren't, they really
did not want to be in this war.
And so by March
of 1918, you have
the treaty-- this between
Russia and the Central Powers--
the Treaty of Brest--
and I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing
everything-- Brest-Litovsk.
The Treaty of Brest-Litovsk,
in which the Russians,
because they were so
desperate, the Bolsheviks
were so desperate
in order to get,
to focus on the
internal civil war that
had emerged in Russia, in
order to consolidate power,
they gave over a huge
amount of territory
to the Central Powers.
And essentially a large
part of European Russia
that is not predominantly--
of Russian ethnicity
went over to the Central Powers.
Now this treaty is important
because it essentially
was the end of World
War I for the Russians.
It essentially was the
end of the Eastern Front.
And it allowed the
Germans to then refocus
on the Western Front, which
allowed the Germans to start
bringing troops back over
to the Western Front.
And they were actually able to
do quite an aggressive Spring
Offensive on the Western Front.
And if it wasn't for
the US at the time,
now being able to reinforce
the Western Front-- remember,
they declared war in
mid-1917-- it's not clear
that the German offensive
might not have been successful
in the spring of 1918.
So the importance
of Brest-Litovsk
is it was the end of
the Eastern Front.
It allowed the Germans to do an
offensive on the Western Front.
And it was a very
strong offensive.
But with the help
of the Americans,
it was not a successful one.
But the actual territorial
gains for the Central Power
of Brest-Litovsk-- I'm sure
I'm mispronouncing it--
were not that significant.
Because in November
1918-- and here
I'm probably falling off
my timeline a little bit.
But right over here
in November 1918,
this is maybe 19-- this
is 1919 right over here.
You have the Central
Powers essentially saying,
oh my God, we're not going
to be able to win this war.
And you have the,
essentially, what
was for a long time
known as Armistice Day.
The 11th the day
of the 11th month--
or the 11th hour
or the 11th hour of the
11th day of the 11th month,
you have an armistice.
And you have the end of World
War I with the Allies winning.
And so the Allies
got to say what
happened to this
territory right over here.